in this capsule we will see the concept
loss minimization
So we do not see the cure of the tax collector
and we saw a rule to change the
parameters so that the tax collector
learn to do less and less
errors but in what we will see my
son is that one can derive the jaws
collectors have with a principle a
little more general to derive
algae learning and one
advantages of this principle there is that we
did we will not be able to develop
several other types behind
learning from the same
principle we hurry higher that
is called the principle of
minimization of losses and the idea is
to see the problem of taking wise
as an optimization problem we
tries to optimize a medium loss on
our prediction for each of
learning examples actually this
what we will do is for each example
drive we will try to
to minimize a distance that we will call
loss did with a loss function
that we call suck sic we note the
6th 'who compares the target yt which is
expected for the example tm
drive with our prediction
made by our model for example our
perception
so we note h2 existed where we put w a
index to indicate the parameters so
the degrees of freedom that allows
to adjust ours our model so w
for one perceive it would be the vector
of weight then it could count too
the beautiful
associated with a prediction so this
function that a distance that checks to
how much our prediction h and close
of the target
yt we will call that a function of
losses under the collector have
the loss function we are going to use
it's the function here it's going to be less 1
time
yt - h2x t times the product that was going
go back w is excited when I remember
that the product because here is the sum
on all elements and wy be xti
so the iem elements of the vector xt
so if we look in detail at this
loss function if the prediction is
good ie if they were there
corresponds to the prediction h2x holds the
blow and 06 actually what if he
rectifies feast h to excite so this term
Syria here is zero
we can import the value of these terms
and if the prediction the loss makes 2 0
on the other hand if the prediction is bad
ie if yt and not equal to buy
xt the loss your correspondents made to the
distance between where the difference actually
this is absolute between what goes into
the function of those and the tax collector
mean w times excited and the threshold to
to cross for the prediction to be
good
so for example if we had that yt is
equal to 1 but that two excited
w in index is equal to zero
so that here it implies that wx
the producer in w is excited must be
smaller than 0 so we remember that
the father be wrong calculation be here and then
next of that he compares this with zero
like that here it's smaller 0 it's going
predict zero otherwise he predicts one so
in this case also actually the problem
we would like
wx exist be greater than 0 then
what we will pay as the loss
associated it's going to be actually wxx the
distance between what I predicted and 0
so in that if that term there would be
negative but we are interested in
distance between that and 0 so we would like
in fact the loss is 2 - w times
excited so in the case where the prediction
in t1
we got 0 the distance between
what I put in drive function
thresholds and the threshold I would have wanted
to exceed it is less times w times excited
and the least we actually have it here
actually if there is and is equal to 1
and that's equal to zero to see 1 - 0 which
is a
but have the least here so have
actually that the loss is going to be less
w9 x external that is going to be a term can
have a loss that will be positive and
who's going to be the distance between what
I gave at the entrance of my function of
thresholds and the threshold I would have wanted
cross to have a prediction that
is vain ok so if that's the function of
losses for the tax collector one is rather
we will see that if we use this
loss function there the principle
hominizing a loss we
allow you to dream of the gatehouse
collector and then we'll see in others
capsules that for other definitions
of losses we will derive from others
elsewhere learning power of
properties sometimes more interesting
so the idea behind the paradigm of the
mine of the loss is that
doing learning is
minimize the average loss between
each of each of the exact targets and
and my prediction that I'm doing for
the excited input to saulcy so we're going
formulate problem understand from
minimization I want to minimize the
average of the loss on my set
drive and for that but degree of
freedom what I can adjust for
minimize the loss it's the parameters
of my model is to improve the
behavior of my model by modifying
its parameters to get the loss on
my whole
German which is the smallest possible
so we could start with a
value of w given that we use
maybe randomly
so we have an example playing here on the 11th
may youth have camped w it's a single
setting then a galley fire that
can load then that's sure access
ziks over the accused y here that would be
the value of the average of the loss of the
go up the training room and when
I would like to do is from
this initial value here I would like
make w adjustments to get a
better value of peace is so what
that I might want to do here
it was at this point this is what I
should move my value from w plus to
left or right to decrease my
average loss on my whole
drive and so if we can
formulate it's like a problem of
local search this is a problem of
research that actually is special in
the sense where here w takes values
continue so it's a bit difficult
to do as with cities like
bing for example to define to define
a neighborhood in this case this is at
clear what is the neighbor of 1.6 la
value wt 1.101 what is his neighbor this
that it's a point 011 or a corner 1 0
1 0 1 1 if you are so we will use
magritte a little bit a little different
adapted for parameters so of
w values ​​that can take
real values ​​to try to optimize
that but it's going to be similar and the
local search ie we will
take w we'll do little
jumps to try to improve our
average loss are as much it has me
really so here is the description more
highest level more intuitive of
comment what we will solve this
problem
so what we prefer not to advance
start by initializing the value of w
a certain point in his vote is associated
a value of the average loss that is
of 6 and 6 throws that my average loss
it's a function that goes on and on
for which I can calculate
drifts and so gradients not what
I could do if look at this
point as well as she is the keeper
so among others from yoda this
game to have the information of 11.6 if
I'm increasing w is what my loss is going
increase or not in this case we have that
so the gradient this point would tell me
that you describe it partially in fact
since we have just one element we have
as well as to their friends just and so
the partial derivatives of the average cost per
report to all surveys would be positive
because if I miss w we see that
actually the function the loss
average increases so what I prefer
it's going in the opposite direction where
she drifted partial to try
since the opposite direction tell me
finally that if I go in the
opposite direction of the guardian I
expect the loss function
average decreases so that would tell me
because the pip function increases in
this election if I should go
in the reverse direction ie to
left and there I could take a step
in that direction to get a
new point to 1 go point I will do
again the assessment of the loss
average on mount the training room
and I will look at what is the divine
partial poses this value of w there again
once we see that if I increase w the
loss function means to increase
so I'll go in the opposite direction
you're not going in that direction
week at this point if I had read value
average simulation debt
drive and the dense that if I
notice if I increase the value of w in
does the loss will diminish so that wants
say that drift and partial she
would have a negative sign so would tell me
that if I'm going to increase the loss
average
it is in this direction that I am
I'm going to have the opposite I want
decrease the average loss should go
right then I could take a step
in that direction if and continue
like that until I get to a
optimum a minimum actually in this case
if this procedure the beard and a
local minimum
we observe that they would have a better
minimum here if we had initialize here
we would eventually arrive at this
point so so something
link langkow has seen this earlier
procedure there called downhill
of gradient because every time we
calculate the gradient so with only one
with a scalar it's the equivalent of
the partial derivatives drift and so
we will go down in the direction
opposite of the gradient to make the for
change the value of our lady for
one hundred because of that we call it the
descent of gaza and like white rice
bing the guardian descent
we can only guarantee to arrive
to a point that is going to be a local minimum
so we did an example in one
dimension where we had a single parameter
adjusted but as long as it happens
if we have two parameters added adjust
so my young people we have a function that
the average loss then that depends on
two possible values ​​that I was only xy
we could have noted them w1 then w2 if
I wanted to refer to the
parameters of a tax collector have by
example the two takers will perceive
so in this case it's actually the gradian
rather than the derivatives will match
to the vectors that point in the
direction where the growth rate of
the higher works ok so if I
was starting my optimization here at 7 in
their six of my xy parameters
but in that if the gradian tip
reid in the direction that increases the
function as much as possible and in the case
of optimizing the average loss
on the training set that's me
would give the direction that
would correspond to changes in my
parameters that would increase the most my
average loss on my former coach
and so for the case at several
dimensions it's going to be the same idea I
will go in the opposite direction to
gradient and I'm going to step into
this direction is there so I'm going
take my point here and then I'm going to
move in the opposite direction of
guardian
according to a certain distance with a
not sure it gave me my new
value to my new value I'm going to
settings i'm going to evaluate the canadian
who's going pretty busy who commits
another direction and institude like
that until forgiveness until
that we arrive at possibly a
optimal to frames so in this case
we could have arrived there
at this point so in this example ci
leaves in two dimensions we can see the
gradian as if imagine that in fact the
function corresponds a species of valier
with valleys hills like
those where hills and the caretaker does
will tell me if I was standing
dance on this ground there in which
direction to that if I take a step I
will increase my altitude the most
quickly possible as much as possible
with a single step and mathematically
done on an infinitely small package but
so the idea of ​​the gradient descent
it's basically to take this
direction there belgians were going in the
opposite
then that's how I go
get as low as possible from in
the land where I find myself for
eventually arrive in a
ok so with this December technique
two guardians I would like to optimize the
average loss so I want to optimize the
loss for all the pairs y txt then
if I want to calculate the gradient of the
average loss
it's going to be the vector of all
drifts and partial of this average
since the drift and so if I did
the partial theory here versus a
wii2 parameter partial view of a
constant times a function that's the
constant times the drift and partial of
the function so I can inserted there
hervé by this one
there again the partial tort
a sum is the sum of the ten
patients
so I can introduce the drift by
the one here so judged that the derivatives
partial of all this expression here
that the average losses
it's actually the average of the derivatives
partial for each of my examples
yt
xt so if I wanted to do the descent
guards as I describe them
previously I will have to calculate the
average derivatives but for all
examples as a whole
drive before you can do
an update from my parents told me
to go in the opposite direction of
gradient hockey and that if I have a big
example a group together
workout it's going to require a lot
calculations before I can adapt my
parameters and have for that we will use
a variant the descent of guards who
the descent of the stochastic guards
the idea of ​​the descent of gaza
stochastic is to update the
parameters from the gradient but
for a single example chosen for you
randomly among our center
drive so what we want to do
we're going to initialize meinau
paramat randomly
then for a number of ideas
ration or until they reach
some downtime we're going to shoot a
example of scoring training
drive a single example excited yt
and we will calculate what is the derivative
partial for each of the parameters of
the loss function
so we will finally calculate the
Canadian versus w and we'll put
up to date each one obama win7 scratching a ride
alpha learning that is going to be the
pot size i'm going to do times the
drift and partial loss by
report to a parameter that I put to
day so if what has changed is that
to update my wai I will not
calculate the average losses so the
the average partial theories of
losses so I'm not going to calculate the of
benchmarks there partial reviews of the
average loss
I'm actually drawing a single example
and then just from this example I
go a calculation and its derivatives
partial to all
settings and updates them
at once
so that's a close to a procedure
which is much more effective when we
has a training set that is
big actually if I have cardinali t2
number of training examples
whose test shot no it's my agent
which contains all my excited parts yt
well I'll do as many updates
parameters as examples
drive after going through everything
the whole training world while
with the procedure of getting off
normal gradient I will make a single bet
up to date after going through all the
training examples and so I say
here that normally with shots one would have
randomly drawn our examples
training that we choose to do
our updates every update
but in fact often what we do
is that we start with the first
example x1 y 1 did an update
then from his takes the second example
exit hours y two made a bet
day is so often in fact
practice we will stick in order to
through our training examples and
that's how we're going to bring forth
stochastic gaza ash
we will go back to the tax collector so
for the tax collector we have the loss we have
defined its - times yt - hd xt times the
product that was going to fit my vector of
allow w and xt and here too I'm doing
partial derivatives by a permit w12
but weight demand because it will be so
if I calculate it here in relation to my
loss for my dad it's round I'm getting
so here we will treat this as a
constant so we do there hervé
partial to products
wx school exist the product that at
the wfe xtc the sum on i of wy sees xt
it so if I do there derivatives
partial of belvis compared to in
do I should use another clue
so we are aroused from wgi excited here and there
also I'm doing partial hervé of
this sum there compared to 1 wy
accurate for example the 1st may
all other terms wgi once existed j
that do not depend on the first of the first
of wxy and also of the first
allow w1 in my sector w all
these other terms are constant by
report to my father
ok so in fact I'm only interested
themes or gitega life and drift
and partial with respect to that term
so we have the parameter once a
constant that excites and I see drift
and that's just excited and if
I do there streets compared to a
element to give it's going to be the der
to spend it going to be excited precisely
times that term there that I treated as
a constant the reason why
I have an approximation here that is
normally I should do
derive also by this term
there here that depends on 2 w
but if I make an approximation that I
suppose and that's actually constant and
I will speak a little more under in
moments
but so we see that the sight of
partial compared to allow wy that
corresponds to that term here for my
loss of the collector and want to heal
to go down stochastic gaza tells me
to take the wy and then put them to
day
subtracting a learning rate
or a step of two gradient centers
alpha times the drift and partial by
relation to my parameters we see that
partial mammary is either here - yt - h
h2x t times excited there is so I have a
less here who will console themselves with those -
there here so I have more alpha xy witnesses
hdx tréfois xti and if you
proud that's exactly the rule of
day where the shore learning for the
collector's gallery
ok so we did find the
learning procedure for the
tax collector by treating as a problem
of minimization to do you so
the advantage here is that if I take
any model and that I am
able to formulate it in the form
of an immunization of a loss of which I
defined a function there it is a
loss function
I define a value of a form
parametric for my prediction hw ii x
but I'm able to train this
model there to treat it as a take
optimization of hominization
losses
it's true if I can calculate prices
facial I can calculate the gradients
so that there could be some
loss functions for which we can not
calculate gradients and in this case
as good we can always do
some approximations and again the
parsley dish this trunk if what we did
we do a little cheat
so I said that derivatives by
report to h
w of x actually she is not defined
when wx and the product 40 wx is
equal to zero
so I have the function cei which is
used in my calculation of my prediction
actually to zero I have a
discontinuity where it changes drastically
from zero to so at this point if in
there is no
we have no derivatives that is defined
so we made any summons when
suppose it's hervé here and
to 0 that heroes also elsewhere
hero here then the heroes here there hervé
so effectively and no variation
so we had to do some
approximation
but we will see other algorithms
next videos where we will not have
easy approximations there and we will
will be able to apply the December war
two guards in a normal way so a
disadvantages actually of precisely
this very hot white faction that we have
in the group of people lawsuits we
make this approximation there and that that
implies among other things that when we go
train a tax collector we will see that
the training curve so the curve
who will show that she is the loss
average or what error or another
what we can look at is the error
classification on our week times
drive is actually also so
a little unstable so we'll see that his
look at the mistake one makes one does not
was watching a class
learning that is rather than a
kept the mistake keep the success rate
the round of carboys classification
often saw that the court was doing that
like that and vary quite a bit
unstable
is that it can be a little annoying for
determine when should we
stop learning in the
next capitulum what are we going to see
how can we define
another value of the loss function
another learning pace via the
Parisian of the loss loss for
fix this problem there may have a
algorithm we learn it training
will be more stable